this is what we're going to go with this
is the cupboard door gonna try and get I
want cyclize at an all in terms of this
just like I've got all my fractions in
terms of this okay so how do I do it
well this is tannic so to let's use that
double angle results right cuz half
angle a double and got really the same
thing just wearing different clothes so
let's see if we can remember 10 2 X
what's the double angle resolve the
expansion for 10 so it's a fraction
that's my clue to remember to 10 X on
the top good alright now if I want to
convert from this into something that
has half acres a set of double angles
all I have to do is to buy all the egg
was my to every single one so if I do
this one by two
you know just become regular tan and
then if I divide these by 2 I'll get to
tan excellent two on the top and one
squared just a straight so decision okay
so since I'm using this I'm naming that
as my common denominator I call it this
just so it's shorter to write so I get
to T Square okay so those of you who
might have seen this before you like oh
I recognize that okay now at this point
remember what I'm trying to get is sine
and cosine as well I want to get all of
them in terms of these tears so your
intuition might leisure fee okay 10
right sorry cousin tan they're all about
right angle triangles nowadays that's
where we started learning about okay so
I can make a right angle triangle with
this ratio inner right tan which to
science is it really in its writing a
drying oil or pass it an adjacent so
let's make for ourselves a right angle
triangle with these two sides of it okay
so if I do this right angle okay and
I'll put my exit before them okay
the opposite side will be here and the
adjacent side would be here
okay now if we want to work out what
this hypotenuse is right I just use
Pythagoras it's the sum of the other two
squared okay so this will be 40 squared
this will mean 1 minus 2t plus 2 squared
right so sorry wait so now you can see
these T squared they mix together so I'm
going to go to that 4 plus 2t squared
plus 1 and this is a perfect square
right T squared plus 1 all squared so if
that's the square of the hypotenuse then
I just take the square root of both
sides just after the positive value
because it'll move so that's where I get
this from ok
does that make sense
all right now just look at that triangle
okay you would probably conclude rightly
that if I want to say it would be
opposite over hypotenuse so I could say
sine X is opposite hypotenuse and
likewise cos x is the other ratio
adjacent on hypotenuse okay so this is
kind of cool I've got 1 2 3 results and
I've avoided this plus/minus business
right that's really good okay now here's
the what the caution I want to give you
put your pens down for a second you'll
have time to continue but I want you to
hear this one because it's important
this triangle okay it's a really handy
tool for remembering one of these ratios
okay because you can draw this you can
work it out by Pythagoras and you can
see you can read the sign cos and tan
off it okay so it's really good you know
how when you're first learning exact
values and you're trying to remember
root 3 or 2 and 1/2 of that kind of
thing so you draw your 30-60-90 triangle
right and you're like this is 1 over 2
so this must move root 3 right so I
compare this as a similar tool
this to help you remember okay but you
mustn't use it as an actual proof okay
can anyone tell me why is it a problem
with using this as a proof for these
results yeah T is greater than one so
this here okay so there's my first
problem okay I'm going to get a triangle
which has negative weights that's a
better problem that actually comes out
of another problem right which is that
all this while it's a running a triangle
right so X has some domain restrictions
on it right what kind of restrictions
are they if it's in this triangle it's
it's got to be a cute right it's got to
be you can't stick an obtuse angle in a
right angle in the same triangle because
then you'll get the right angle and the
obtrusive yeah okay
so therefore this only works for this
domain okay and that's not good right
these actually work these identities
they work all the time okay almost seen
a second so we need a better way to
prove it so I still like this as a way
of remembering what the ratios are but
if you get lost approve them this won't
be enough so let me show you how to do
that
how did we prove that tan was equal to
this we didn't use a triangle we used
identities right your double angle
expansions that we learned from earlier
in the term only the youth right so I
can actually use exactly the same
approach just sine and cosine right
here's the way I'm going to think about
it just like starting the 10 2 X let's
do sign first so sine 2x
what's the expansion to sine x cos x
right okay now this is double so I want
to convert it into halves so divide
every angle by 2 and you get this okay
so far so good now remember here I'm
trying to go I'm trying to get
everything in terms of this tea business
is 10 X 1/2 okay so if I'm gonna try to
get these into tandoc's of X onto what
am I going to do I'm gonna have to
introduce some division here right and I
apologize the steps that are going to
follow they are a big hand to is why
would you do that
but there aren't that many sets they're
quite easy to follow so you won't have
to reproduce the two each time something
he's the first thing I'm gonna do I'm
gonna divide by one but the kind of one
I'm gonna divide by is sine squared plus
cos squared okay so what I've divided by
one so I haven't changed anything okay
all right now if I want to get this into
Tanz I'm gonna have to divide right what
should i / well to turn sign into ten
you divide by cursor right so I'm going
to divide everything through by not just
one cosine but cosine squared because
I've got a sine squared there so I'm
going to divide by two to match up so if
I divide numerator and denominator all
of the terms by closed square this is
what I'm gonna do
divided by cos squared
x12 let's just take it one at a time
on the top here I'll put big wagons just
to make it really obvious right I've got
to sign X 2 because X 1/2 divided by cos
square okay ok till the second let's
just get the bottom as well on the
bottom got side squared divided by cos
squared and then I'll cause squared
divided by cos square okay now that
we've actually divide everything through
now let's start to cancel one of these
cosines will cancel with that one yeah
so cancel cancel okay so what am I left
with on the top sign on close that's
tuned okay what happens on the bottom
here sine squared on cos squared that's
ten squared cos squared on cos squared
that's 1 and of course this is the T
that we were working with before
and just to put it back in the order
that we were looking at earlier so
that's kind of company oh we got the
same result as a thumbs up right and now
you can rinse it repeat and do exactly
the same thing I mean Chris I'll this
time since you've seen the steps I'm
gonna do it a little bit quicker I'm
gonna go straight to the half angle one
right so cos x hmm double angle for cos
is it's very similar the Pythagorean I
did it right it's cos squared minus sine
squared cos squared minus sine squared
so I'm gonna have half angles on this
side
that check out okay again I'm going to
divide by one so there's my long awkward
one and then again I'm going to divide
everything by cos swear okay and this
time I'm not gonna write this
intermediate step I'm actually gonna do
them one by one
cos squared on college square one side
squared on closed squared square on the
bottom 1 plus tan squared 1 minus T
squared 1 plus T Smith
okay so let's review what are the
results we start off with X be sorry 10x
onto being equal to T that's how that's
what makes it the T results okay so
therefore just 1/10 the whole thing okay
that's true tea you can remember that
using the double angle formula okay and
then when you go to sign this is named
marina different denominator okay cuz
remember it's opposite on adjacent and
this is opposite on hypotenuse right so
that's why different sorry different the
same and lastly